Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Five, Episode Eight: film, from the silent era to the 1980s.
A number of Danes have, in the course of time, become internationally famous as film actors or as directors.
Around the year 1900, the first films were recorded in Denmark.
They were reports about society.
In 1906, Nordisk Film was founded.
After that, the Danish film industry grew quickly and became known in many countries.
Asta Nielsen, who lived from 1881 to 1972, was Denmark's first film star.
She had great success with roles in silent films and recorded many films in Germany in the first half of the 1900s.
She was celebrated for her erotic charisma and her ability to express the whole range of feelings on the screen.
Carl Th.
Dreyer, who lived from 1889 to 1968, is the most important director in the older Danish film history.
Films such as Vredens Dag, "Day of Wrath", from 1943, and the French La passion de Jeanne d'Arc, "The Passion of Joan of Arc", from 1928, have secured Dreyer fame.
Dreyer's close-ups and slow film tempo distinguished his films.
His film Ordet, "The Word", from 1955, is based on a drama by Kaj Munk, and the film culminates in a scene where a young mother is awakened to life from the dead.
Dreyer depicts the gripping miracle with an outstanding use of close-ups and cuts.
Early film classics are, in addition, Astrid Henning-Jensen, who lived from 1914 to 2002, and Bjarne Henning-Jensen, 1908 to 95, with Ditte Menneskebarn from 1946, after the novel by Martin Andersen Nexø; Johan Jacobsen's, who lived from 1912 to 72, Soldaten og Jenny, "The Soldier and Jenny", from 1947; and Henning Carlsen's, who lived from 1927 to 2014, Sult, "Hunger", from 1966, after the novel of the same name by the Norwegian author Knut Hamsun.
The three films have poverty and exclusion as themes and are based on novels and plays respectively.
Ditte Menneskebarn takes place at the beginning of the 20th century and is about a poor girl who is born outside marriage and is exposed to violence and abuse.
She also becomes pregnant herself without being married and is trapped in the vicious circle of poverty.
Soldaten og Jenny depicts the relationship between a young woman and a soldier who meet by chance in a bar.
Jenny has previously had an abortion, which at that time was forbidden, and is now threatened with punishment and exclusion.
Henning Carlsen's Sult takes place at the end of the 1800s and is about a young writer who wanders around Norway's capital Kristiania, today's Oslo.
He has been thrown out of his rented room and has no money for food.
He tries to pawn his few belongings, even his glasses and the buttons on his clothes, and he humiliates himself to get a job.
His situation becomes more and more desperate, all the while he moves among the city's citizens as if he had no problems.
The period from 1950 to 1975 was a heyday for commercial folk comedies.
The biggest success and Denmark's most seen film became Alice O'Fredericks's, who lived from 1899 to 1968, and Jon Iversen's, 1889 to 1964, film version of Morten Korch's, 1876 to 1954, novel De røde heste, "The Red Horses", from 1950.
The film tells the dramatic story of how a young farmer saves his farm from falling into the hands of villains by winning a big horse race.
Erik Balling, who lived from 1924 to 2005, learned from the folk comedies and delighted audiences with the film series Olsen-banden, "The Olsen Gang", of a total of 14 films, the first from 1968.
The films are inspired by cartoons and are about a fictional Danish criminal gang.
With Egon Olsen as leader, the gang has big, cunning plans to commit a heist that will make them millionaires, but which mostly goes completely wrong in a way that you have to laugh at.
The film series was copied in Norway and Sweden and was popular, in German, in the communist East Germany.
Erik Balling was also a much used director on TV.
The TV series Matador takes place in Denmark of the 1930s and 1940s.
The setting for the story is the fictional Zealand provincial town of Korsbæk.
We follow its inhabitants and experience their family life, careers, love and struggle with gender roles.
The norms of the time and important historical events are described.
The series' 24 episodes were first shown on television in 1978 to 82 and have later been rebroadcast countless times.
Matador is the most watched TV series in Denmark ever.
The script was especially written by the author Lise Nørgaard, who lived from 1917 to 2023.
Many events in the series are inspired by her own childhood and youth.
Films for children are an important part of Danish film art.
Busters Verden, "Buster's World", from 1984, by Bille August, born 1948, is a classic within this genre.
Busters Verden is based on a novel by the popular children's book author Bjarne Reuter, born 1950.
In the film we meet Buster, who has a hard time both at home and at school, where he is always bullied.
But his imagination and talent for magic help him through many of the difficulties.
In 1982, the Folketing gave Danish children's films better financial conditions, and thereby recognised the artistic importance of the children's film genre.
Excellent films about children and young people, which were also for adults, were also produced.
Nils Malmros, born 1944, directed, for example, a long series of films about young people, among others Kundskabens træ, "The Tree of Knowledge", from 1981.
The film is about bullying and crushes in a class of pubescent children.
Some friends are shut out of the community, and romantic relationships begin and end very suddenly.
The adults, both the teachers at the school and the parents, do not understand the young people's lives and their relationships with each other.
Many cinema-goers, young as well as adult, often recognised themselves in Malmros's depiction of early youth.
In Danish: an actor is a skuespiller, a film director is a filminstruktør, and a TV series is a tv-serie.
Here is your recap for Episode Eight.
The first films were recorded in Denmark around 1900, and Nordisk Film was founded in 1906.
Asta Nielsen, 1881 to 1972, was Denmark's first film star.
Carl Th.
Dreyer, 1889 to 1968, is the most important older director, with Vredens Dag in 1943, La passion de Jeanne d'Arc in 1928, and Ordet in 1955, based on Kaj Munk.
Ditte Menneskebarn from 1946, Soldaten og Jenny from 1947, and Sult from 1966 have poverty and exclusion as themes.
1950 to 1975 was a heyday of folk comedies; De røde heste from 1950 is Denmark's most seen film.
Erik Balling made 14 Olsen-banden films, from 1968, and the TV series Matador, shown 1978 to 82, with 24 episodes, set in the fictional town of Korsbæk; it is the most watched series ever, with scripts by Lise Nørgaard.
Busters Verden from 1984 is a children's film classic; in 1982 the Folketing improved conditions for children's films.
Nils Malmros made Kundskabens træ in 1981.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
In which decades does most of the TV series Matador take place?
Option A: The 1880s and 1890s.
Option B: The 1930s and 1940s.
Option C: The 1960s and 1970s.
[DA] I hvilke årtier udspiller det meste af tv-serien Matador sig?  A: 1880’erne og 1890’erne  |  B: 1930’erne og 1940’erne  |  C: 1960’erne og 1970’erne
The answer is B: The 1930s and 1940s.
It appeared in the June 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: 1930’erne og 1940’erne
Question 2.
Who is known for having written the script for the TV series Matador?
Option A: Anders Thomas Jensen.
Option B: Lise Nørgaard.
Option C: Nils Malmros.
[DA] Hvem er kendt for at have skrevet manuskriptet til tv-serien Matador?  A: Anders Thomas Jensen  |  B: Lise Nørgaard  |  C: Nils Malmros
The answer is B: Lise Nørgaard.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Lise Nørgaard
Question 3.
Which Danish TV series describes, among other things, daily life and historical events in the period 1929 to 47?
Option A: Krøniken.
Option B: Borgen.
Option C: Matador.
[DA] Hvilken dansk tv-serie beskriver blandt andet dagligliv og historiske begivenheder i perioden 1929-47?  A: Krøniken  |  B: Borgen  |  C: Matador
The answer is C: Matador.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Matador
That's the end of this part.
Well done.